ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde wir haben für
heute richtig was zu tun der weg auch
ein gutachter der macht mir sogar
geschafft geht weg junge aber doch schon
wieder sollen
[Musik]
wer einen audi soziale kann ich diese
teile denn jetzt gegen die einsammeln
oder so ich weiß es nicht könnte mich an
und in die kommentare schreiben
wir haben für heute wieder zehn sekunden
später den hab ich gar nicht gesehen die
chance dass so ein blöder unterwasser
babo also einen dreizack fallen lässt
ist richtig klein und das habt ihr mir
auch in die kommentare schon morgen
schwein danke mir geht es sehr gut sind
sagt pack ich einfach mal hier meine
wertvolle truhe genauso wie die nautilus
schale und ihr seht auch schon ich habe
mich hier schon ein bisschen vorbereitet
denn
werden heute eine neue hülle suchen
es wird nicht so episch wie ich gerade
gesagt haben bevor wir uns allerdings in
höhe suchen können wir noch einmal kurz
nach unseren spielern hier schauen hier
ist nichts geschlüpft hier auch nicht ja
auch nicht haben wir auf jeden fall eine
menge schildkröten hier rumgammeln
allerdings noch immer keine horn stellte
da habt ihr mir wach wird in die
schaufel in der hand mir wurde in die
kommentare geschrieben dass die
warnschilder wohl erst auftreten wenn
die schildkröten so richtig ausgewachsen
sind das heißt wir müssen jetzt warten
bis die schildkröten erwachsen sind und
dann können wir die hersteller bekommen
um es dann schlussendlich irgendwann
eine helden zu machen mit denen die
unter wasser atmen können die farbe hier
wird auch so langsam also sobald das
alles hier voll ist werde ich das dann
auch ein bisschen schöner machen da
müssen wir mal gedanken machen
allerdings wie gerade schon gesagt wieso
umsatz erhöhen ihr wurde die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich diesen kuhstall weg
machen soll und die tiere vielleicht auf
eine gesonderte insel packen soll seine
kleine tier insel was haltet ihr davon
könnte mir auch mal gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben wir hier unsere
kleine bahnstrecke können wir noch nicht
so richtig benutzen weil naja die jetzt
halt bisher zirka ein zehntel des weges
klang hier vorne wird unsere bahnstrecke
dann ankommen auf der anderen insel wenn
das dann mal endlich irgendwann fertig
sein sollte allerdings würde ich sagen
geben wir jetzt mal hier vorne in so ein
paar berge rein weil ich mir einfach
denke ich glaub ich pack das boot
einfach mal direkt hier vorne
also ich kann mir vorstellen dass in
solchen bergen hat immer kranke höhlen
drin sind nach vorne sind auf jeden fall
höhlen eingänge hier wurde sogar auch
schon ich würde sogar sagen dass wir
hier direkt rein gehen und jetzt meine
lieben freunde sind wir wieder
[Musik]
es ist jetzt nicht so groß wie die höhe
hier vorne geht runter ich sehe
natürlich auch direkt wieder ein creeper
da vorne
allerdings habe ich mir für solche
situationen der extra pfeil und bogen
mitgenommen damit ich dir jetzt mal aus
der ferne attackieren kann da unten ist
sogar noch einen keeper da komm ich
allerdings leider nicht ran
mir wurde auch in die kommentare
geschrieben luca du hast ein schild
warum benutzt du dein chef
und was mir auch geschrieben wurde luca
die fackeln immer nur rechts entpacken
das wird mit zwei letzten schon mal
geschrieben aber das werde ich heute auf
jeden fall auch noch ein bisschen mehr
der gutherzigen heißen damit ich hier
halt relativ gut den ausgang wieder
finde da vorne stellt eine spinne
wir haben war nicht erst mal die spinn
ich weiß nicht ob ich eine schlucht ist
oder so was sieht so aus als ob es die
rechts auf jeden fall gehörig weit
runter geht also die höhle ist doch
größer als ich das im ersten moment
erwartet hatte es geht hier überall
weiter hier vorne auch hier oh mein gott
[Musik]
ich werde heute auch auf jeden fall
deutlich anders vorgehen als ich das
beispielsweise in der letzten episode
gemacht habe und zwar werde ich
konstruktiver vorgehen ich werde
produktiver vorgehen das heißt ich werde
erstmal alles ausleuchten und mich
danach auf das erz abbauen konzentrieren
aber hier kannst du ja gar nicht alles
ausleuchten guckt euch mal an wie riesig
dass sie es sie gibt schon wieder so
krass runter ok ich werde auf jeden fall
ein bisschen anders heute vorgehen ich
werde erstmal alles ausleuchten ich
werde mir erstmal überblick verschaffen
was ihr überhaupt los ist ich werde
nicht so vorgehen wie in der letzten
folge dass sich erstmalig auf die ärzte
konzentrieren alles mitnehmen was ich
irgendwie abbaue
jetzt wird profi minecraft geschichte
geschrieben nach du scheiße denkt da
geht's
wir haben eine mine fort also was geht
denn jetzt ab das ist ja normal kranke
ich dachte ja man aber es ist so sind
senkt diamant wieder weg weg weg weg
ich darf mich hier nicht schon wieder
den tod holen ich habe mir hier vorne
gerade schon eine kleine base aufgebaut
einfach nur bestehend aus einer werkbank
einer kiste und im ofen wo ich schon mal
so ein bisschen eisen schmelz und was
ich dann auch hier reinpacken kann damit
ich nicht die ganze zeit alles mit mir
rumschleppen
und das wenn ich sterben sollte
zumindest einige sachen gesichert sind
es macht jetzt gerade keinen sinn dass
ich hier zum beispiel das reisen mit der
glücks spitzhacke abbauen weil ich bei
dem eisen jesu blöcke raus bekommen und
dabei bringt glück einfach nichts also
glück bringt wirklich wenig redstone
abbau oder smaragde oder diamanten und
dafür musste ich diamanten allerdings
erst mal finden geht schon wieder weiter
das kannst du doch keinem erzählen was
dass hierfür ein
hier war ich schon hier ist der kiste
erste gäste
wir haben gesagt wir haben richtig viele
schieben das ist richtig gut für unser
für unsere bahn die wir machen wollen
die lore kann ich eigentlich auch mal
mitnehmen dann haben wir da auf jeden
fall schon mal was sie sind auch noch
schienen halter schweden besser könnte
es nicht laufen in dieser höhe der
frisur
oh mein gott ich bin richtig happy
ich bin richtig happy gerade wir haben
so eine pappe es könnte wirklich nicht
besser laufen als das dass gerade der
fall ist meine lieben freunde und jetzt
nehmen wir die diamant spitzhacke mit
glück und schauen wie viele diamanten
herausbekommen hier kommen direkt drei
diamanten aus einem block hier kommen
noch eine raus und hier kommt ja immer
mehr
wir haben schon sechs jahren obwohl wir
nur drei bisher abgebaut haben
das findet diamant ada was geht denn
hier ab wir haben 16
ich will nicht dass diese folge heute
endet das ist ja unfassbar was wir hier
für ein krankes glück haben mit der höhe
und mit den ärzten und mit dem eine
spitzhacke schrott ich brauche jetzt
auch mal den ersten redstone heute ab
und da kommt erst mal hier
das war ein block noch eine noch einer
aus drei blöcken redstone habe ich 19
ich würde allerdings sagen dass wir erst
mal zurück laufen zu unserer base um die
sachen so ein bisschen zu sichern
da kann ich jetzt einfach den fackeln
nachlaufen die ich auf die rechte seite
gesetzt habe und dann werden wir ganz
diamanten kaum schönere ein redstone
kommt ihr schön rein das gold jetzt kann
ich auch direkt schmelzen alter wir
gehen richtig bedachte gerade und das
freut mich übertrieben ich werde mir
auch direkt schon mal eine neue
spitzhacke machen damit wir nicht die
ganze zeit unsere komische glück
spitzhacke da missbrauchen müssen jetzt
gerne kommen hier ein feuerstein die
lore und so weiter und so fort ich bin
richtig happy
ich bin richtig happy das ist eine
richtig gute episode bisher ich nehme
diese spinnennetze jetzt auch einfach
mal mit weil wir aus der seite später
wolle machen können und das ist gut für
mein leuchtturm den ich ja irgendwann
geplant habe den ich auf die andere
insel setzen möchte so dass wir auch aus
weiter entfernung immer sehen wo wir zu
hause sind und wo unsere heimat insel
ist ich finde das aber eigentlich ganz
schön dass wir auf dieser insel bleiben
viele haben wir natürlich auch
geschrieben luca
warum geht es für mich auf dieser andere
insel also da wo ich jetzt gerade bin
ist ja deutlich geiler hier gibt es viel
mehr möglichkeiten blabla ich finde
eigentlich ganz schön wenn wir so ein
bisschen eingeschränkt und unsere
möglichkeiten sind das tatsächlich
komisch und ich feiere sei einfach wenn
wir dann beispielsweise hier ist eine
blume die ja ich dachte dass wir eine
spinne oder so ähnlich feiert dann wenn
wir beispielsweise mal so ein trip
machen ab und zu und dann sagen hey wir
gehen jetzt mal hier irgendwie auf eine
insel und gehen dann mal irgendwie in
der höhle oder so dass man sowas dann
einfach immer mit unserer kleinen
bahnverbindung macht und dementsprechend
dann auf diese inseln fährt um halt zu
schauen hey dann ich weiß gar nicht was
ich gerade rede
ich bin einfach nur total happy was wir
hier gerade alles finden lover hier
vorne baue ich mal zu der zwischenzeit
können wir auch mal kurz gucken was hier
oben ist weil das hier ist ja der weg zu
der mine bei mine muss ich ihnen wie man
hermine denken und dementsprechend harry
potter es wurde damit gar nichts zu tun
hat es ist echt crazy was wir hier für
um mengen an erzen haben ich könnte die
ganze zeit nur ärzte an bord aber das
wäre extrem langweilig und sage und
nebenbei bord zu haben die ganze zeit
zum erzabt vergisst du halt irgendwann
das hier natürlich auch monster sind
also ich muss mich glaube ich wirklich
erstmal ein bisschen ausleuchten und
erkunden konzentrieren aber man kann
jetzt noch ne kiste
wir haben so schienen okay was man damit
soll weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau wir
haben hier lohnen kerne oh mein gott das
ist richtig gut
wir müssen doch irgendwann die farbe auf
jeden fall noch mal ein bisschen weiter
ausbauen die wir gerade haben ich werde
auch hier die ganzen schienen mitnehmen
weil man braucht halt verschieden
richtig viel eisen und das ist richtig
gut dass wir so viel schienen hier haben
für unsere bahnstrecke ich habe das
gefühl ich wiederhole mich die ganze
zeit gerade beim kommentieren das ist
natürlich auch schwierig zu kommentieren
wenn man einfach sich in der höhle
befindet ich dachte die höhle die wir
unter unserer insel hatten die war
riesig aber das ist eine ganz andere
liga und ich entdecke immer wieder neue
gänge
die folge sind die fackeln es echt gut
dass ich die alle auf die rechte seite
setzte damit ich halt nachher sehen kann
wo ich lang laufen kann
ich bin auf 180 nehmen dass sie wieder
mitten in der nacht auf und dann hat man
wirklich mal ein bisschen schüssel ein
kräftiger was geht hier ab
was geht hier ab das sind ja sowas von
unnormal riesig lange gänge alter
schwede ich komme gar nicht klar
ich laufe die ganze zeit nur um und bin
beim ausleuchten und es gibt überall
noch weiter
hier sind um mein gott er sagte da kann
man mal gucken wie lange bekommen okay
nur ein
es kann natürlich auch nicht immer
klappen ich hab halt trotzdem die ganze
zeit so ein bisschen schiss dass wir
gleich auf den sport treffen dem er
vorhin schon entdeckt haben da vorne ist
ein krieg hier kann man auch eben
abschießen und dann werde ich auch
gleich mal einen eimer rausholen und mir
hier wasser mitnehmen dass wenn ich in
lava fallen sollte oder wir aber sehen
dass sich die zumindest ein bisschen weg
machen kann um ärzte beispielsweise
besser abzubauen
hier vorne ist er hier ist alles voll
mit oh mein gott dessen krieg aber guckt
euch das an anleger wie bunt das ist wie
viele ärzte einfach sind was ihr mann
ist springt er mir das ganze reisen in
die luft was ist nicht nur los in dieser
höhle hier sondern was geht generell in
meiner kompletten minecraft welt hat ich
bin sowas von geisteskrank happy mit
meiner kompletten map einfach das ist
unfassbar viele leute haben mich immer
gefragt luca hast du irgendwie zieht
genommen im internet gefunden
ich habe das ding einfach so zufällig
als sich erstellen lassen und es ist
unnormal glücklich gewesen fasst sich
einfach für eine welt zugeteilt bekommen
habe
ich werde jetzt auch übrigens immer dort
wo ich schon war und wohl nichts mehr
essen das ganze so ein bisschen zu bauen
damit wir einfach so ein bisschen
übersicht haben
aber schaut euch dort merkt dass hier
allein an gold redstone hier ist
lapislazuli kohle
hier ist auch redstone da müsste das
bonner seine wir vorhin gesehen haben
ich nehme noch mal schnell hier eben das
eisen mit ich platze auch wirklich aus
allen nähten also nicht nur in real life
gern wäre ich gerade fette pizza
gefressen habe sondern auch hier in
minecraft weil mein ganzes inventars
einfach voll fit mit ärzten die ich hier
abgebaut habe alter was geht denn ab
guckt euch das eigentlich auch irgendwo
erst ab und kommen wieder einen neuen
teil des höhlensystems es ich habe gar
keinen plan was sie gerade abgeht
allerdings konzentriere ich mich jetzt
erstmal hier rechts auf den spanner
hiervon habe ich alles abgebaut bzw
eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht erst auf
häufig wurde hier vorne müsste das
bonner seien die frage ist ja hier sei
die frage ist jetzt baue ich den spot ab
möchte ich den aus weil ich weiß nicht
was mir diese giftspinnen bringen stoppt
man muss hier einst poller so
ausleuchten dass man an jeder seite
irgend eine fackel daran setzt dass man
hier noch die zwei kisten alter hier ist
auch ein richtiges im openair überhaupt
ne hier zack und hier an die seite jetzt
auch noch eine fackel eben beim jetzt
dürfte da eigentlich nichts mehr spawn
wir gehen allerdings hier erst mal den
weg lang hier vorne doch ein smaragd den
kann ich auch mal abbauen da haben wir
auf jeden fall jetzt mehrere aus
bekommen so dass viele stück gerade hier
vorne geht es auch noch hoch alter was
geht denn ab was geht denn ab bei dieser
höhle
ich bin so begeistert ich kann sich oft
genug sagen dass noch ein smaragd die
nämlich auch mal direkt mit mal schauen
wie viel wir jetzt rauskriegen werden
vorher 5 jetzt haben wir acht wir haben
drei stück raus bekommen diese glück
drei spitzhacke lohnt sich so was von
übertrieben es ist so krass es ist auch
so heftig wie viele wege es einfach gibt
in dieser höhle
ich habe meine pace jetzt schon wieder
verloren die müssen wir auf jeden fall
gleich mal suchen gehen
ich wollte eigentlich eine ganz normale
komme ich gehe mal herunter alter das
ist ja unfassbar was wir hier das noch
mal so eine kleine gift stände alter
darf mich nicht stechen sie hat mich
gestochen
oh mein gott ich bin sehr begeistert
ich glaube man kann es auch auf jeden
fall raus hören dass ich total happy
gerade bin aber was geht hier den ablauf
ist sie natürlich auch noch mit der gold
spitzhacke abbauen also was ist denn
hier los
tja das wasser da oben mal eben zu bauen
nämlich mal kurz im groove stein damit
wir nicht die ganze zeit weggeschwemmt
werden von wo kommt das von hier oben
alter immer hier gibt's auch wieder so
krank weiter mit den ganzen blocken
[Musik]
jetzt hat sie nicht ausdenken
das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken ich
habe gerade meine pace hier vorne
wiedergefunden bau einfach nur kohle ab
und findet diamanten dicker aber nicht
nur einen nicht nur zwei einfach drei
lenker das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken
ich baue mir hier vorne jetzt mal
einfach die zähne ab damit sich die
basic auch so ein bisschen schön mache
das mit der glücks spitze gab es bei uns
natürlich nicht so schnell dafür werde
ich jetzt mal einfach eben mir noch
schnell eine eisen spitzhacke bauen zack
zack zack zack hier das eisenbahn
ich wollte die basic nämlich ein
bisschen schöner machen denn das soll
hier nicht einfach so eine base werden
von wegen hey da packe ich mal kurz ein
paar sachen werde wenn ich aus der halle
raus geht an dem ich das wichtigste mit
nee wir haben ja ganz klar hier schon
gesehen dass das hier eine riesen höhle
sein wird hier vorne geht es ja auch
noch mal die sich weiter da war ich
überall noch gar nicht ihr könnt ja noch
viel mehr diamanten seien als redstone
ich muss noch mit einem lapislazuli da
hinten also es gibt auch noch viele wege
die ich noch gar nicht so richtig
entdeckt habe
deswegen werden wir auf jeden fall
wiederkommen und da macht es sinn dass
diese dates ja auch ein bisschen schön
ist und wenn ich hier jetzt gerade dann
auch den weg nach draußen bauer und so
weiter und so fort ist das ja ich ganz
geil hier vorne kann ich uns auch mal
weg runter bauen beziehungsweise mal
kurz den wassereimer nehmen und das hier
über die lava setzen damit wir zumindest
das gold auch noch mitnehmen können ich
werde mir auch mal eben schnell noch ein
paar faxen machen da habe ich nämlich
alle schon verbraucht ich habe schon
mehr als
es war jetzt los kurz vom kotzen hier
ich hab schon mehr als zwei komplette
fackel stacks verbraucht beim einer
entdeckung durch diese ganze höhle
hierdurch aber ist auch wichtig dass man
alles ausleuchten damit er nicht noch
mehr monsters bauen und so weiter und so
fort
hier vorne mache ich jetzt erstmal alles
zu obsidian damit wir uns hier auf jeden
fall sicher darüber bewegen können und
nebenbei natürlich ganze zeit
ausleuchten das nimmt uns jetzt ein
bisschen die helligkeit weg hier mit der
lava ich finde da gehört auch in höhlen
immer so ein bisschen mit dazu dass ich
dann immer ganz geil aus aber damit wir
uns hier sauber darüber bewegen können
dass das auf jeden fall gut wenn das
nicht mehr vorhanden ist man schnell
erfolg hätte
auch brandon das plötzlich egal was geht
hier ab
ich bin so unnormal verliebt in dieser
höhle das geht ja gar nicht mehr klar
ich hab wirklich noch nie so eine höhle
in minecraft gesehen ich weiß dass er
jetzt auch letztens das neue update raus
kann beziehungsweise die geht es direkt
weiter mit der lava ich weiß dass
letztes oder hier gibt's auch direkt
weiter mit der lava alter schwede was
geht denn hier ab vier grad sagen das
jahr dem nächsten update rauskommt
beziehungsweise rauskamen wo er
mannschaften noch mal krassere
[Musik]
das
wenn ich diese lager verbrannt werde mit
meinem ganze staffel jetzt direkt
aufgabe beendet ich habe auf jeden fall
gehört dass bald richtig kranke höhlen
in minecraft herausfand diamanten
gefunden
du kannst kein erzählen was das für ein
verdammtes glück es was ich hier habe
wir vorne so ein großer konferenzraum
und hier um die ecke das habe ich gerade
schon so ein bisschen raus liefern
können befindet sich auch tatsächlich
noch ein verdammt das bonner ich weiß
nämlich den geradezu krass ausgeleuchtet
habe oder ob das auch so klappt aber wir
müssen wirklich unsere dings finden
unsere kleine base ich weiß auch gar
nicht was ich jetzt gerade mal liegen
lassen soll ich das jetzt einfach mal
den bruchstein hier und ein bisschen
eichenholz sollen damit ich das jetzt
zumindest noch mitnehmen kann hier vorne
waren wir auf jeden fall auch noch nicht
ich weiß nicht mehr wo unsere dings ist
hier vorne ist noch eine kiste und mein
gott wenn jetzt wieder irgend was drin
ist was krasse ich lasse es sein wenn
man die drei knochen hier damit wir
namensschild noch mitnehmen können alter
was ist denn hier los ich muss jetzt
wieder mein eisenerz nehmen weil ich
einfach keinen cobblestone hab mir mal
kurz die lava zuzubauen die vorne waren
wir schon habe ich schon fackeln
hingesetzt ich werde hier vorne
allerdings auch mal so ein bisschen das
ganze aus möchten die kommen hier unten
den ort kennen wir hier muss irgendwo
hier ist meine pace hier ist meine pace
ok wir waren doch nicht so weit weg wie
ich dachte ich werde mir auch ganz kurz
die andere truhe noch nehmen und die man
hier neben setzen dass sie eine große
truhe haben ist glaube ich auch wichtig
dann kann ich die werkbank einfach hier
draufsetzen und wir können die ganzen
sachen mal hier drin lagern
beziehungsweise noch kurz eben braten
wir haben hier unten auch noch gold
digger was geht ab hier ist noch im
redstone am start den wir auch noch mit
dicker ich bin so übertrieben heftig für
glücklich wie diese folge heute glauben
nicht aufdecken zwei diamanten alter die
lava oder so hört zumindest nicht sich
pause mehr ab sagt junge
jetzt aber ist schnell zu bauen das
heißt dahinter ist auch noch lava das
heißt ich brauche ihn jetzt mal ab und
versuche so ein bisschen pastor
umzusetzen ist darunter lavallee den
kann ich auf jeden fall mitnehmen
wir haben hier auch wieder vier
diamanten und gebückt da hat glück jetzt
nicht so viel gebracht lade lieber gott
was ist das hier heute für eine episode
es geht wirklich gerade in die top drei
meiner schönsten minecraft episoden 1
auf jeden fall fand nicht die haus folge
sehr schön wo ich mein haus gebaut habe
das mit der farm von nicht auch schön
und die höllen folge fand ich auch sehr
geil aber dass hier gerade was wir hier
entdecken ich bin in der aufnahme gerade
bei fast zwei stunden muss das gleich
alles runter schneiden aber ich freue
mich schon so auf den schnitt werde ich
einfach weiß dass wir haben hier schon
wieder zum charakter alter wie viele
kamen raus nur einer leider ich weiß
schon wieder im schnitt dass ich mich
die ganze zeit wieder mit mir freuen
werde obwohl ich das ja eigentlich
gerade alles schon hier erlebe es ist
unfassbar ich bewege mich auch gerade
wieder viel zu weit weg von unserer
kleinen von unserem kleinen spot da
hinten da kommen zombies an wir haben
hier unten ich gehe jetzt auch nicht
mehr runter wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
zu einem ende gekommen
[Musik]
ich lasse euch das gerade einfach mal
drin weil das was ich hier abgebaut habe
war erst noch ein bisschen red sondern
muss immer mehr als sonne war da
plötzlich noch eisen das ist auch noch
hier vorne dann habe ich dahinter
gesehen dass da noch eine menge gold ist
hier vorne und jetzt sind hier wieder
diamanten de hat diese szene gerade
beschreibt einfach diese höhle perfekt
das ist so wie wenn du in den apfel
beißt und findet darin plötzlichen
lottoscheinen gewinns damit 5 millionen
euro
was ich halt auch einfach krass findet
die tatsache dass unsere diamant
spitzhacke das seht ihr unten einfach
schon zur hälfte aufgebraucht ist und
ich habe wirklich damit kein scheiß
abgebaut
die steine oder keine ahnung was sondern
mich wirklich auf wichtige dinge
konzentriert stone smaragde reisen etc
und da sieht man einfach wie viel wir
dann tatsächlich auch gefunden haben ich
werde jetzt die vorne nochmal das gold
das recht der restliche einschmelzen
gehe die ganze kohle mal eben raus
nehmen hier brauchen wir auch nicht so
viel drin und hier auch nicht alles mal
hier rein packen und schaut euch das
jetzt bitte einfach mal an was wir jetzt
alles bekommen haben
allein das hier 36 diamanten ich weiß
dass in dieser ganzen höhle noch eine
menge ärzte auf uns warten und wie auch
ganz ganz viele gänge nicht mal
ansatzweise erkundet haben
von daher müssen wir hier auf jeden fall
noch mal hin also keine sorge wir werden
hier auf jeden fall der ganz mein gott
ich dachte die wären qr-code man da rede
ich gerade darüber dass sie eine menge
noch völlig unentdeckt ist jetzt kommt
direkt wieder so ne riesen höhlensystem
ich will am liebsten hier weiter
erkunden leute ich glaube ihr wollt das
auch aber wir müssen die sachen jetzt
wirklich mal in sicherheit bringen ich
brauche hier vorne noch eben die
schienen ab die folge ist jetzt
tatsächlich auch länger geworden als ich
wollte das schon sehr kleine xxl folge
ich habe auch schon wieder vergessen wo
ich mich jetzt gerade hoch gebaut haben
vorne habe ich gerade noch ein smaragd
gefunden und hier an der anderen seite
sogar auch noch
die muss ich auf jeden fall auch noch
eben mitnehmen hier sind auch noch ganz
viele unentdeckte orte hier geht auch
noch das komische systeme weiter dass
noch ein spanner tatsächlich alter
schwede hinten habe ich ja schon
ausgeleuchtet aber hier ist dann noch
einer
mein gott das gold nämlich hier vorne
immer noch mit ich kann es wirklich
nicht sein lassen hier alles mitzunehmen
würde aber trotzdem sagen ich suche
jetzt mal einen gang nach vorne wieder
und werde mich jetzt nach oben bauen und
euch das ganze urteile zeigen
[Musik]
wir sind oben angekommen leute
sind auf dem berg deswegen habe ich mich
auch guckt euch mal an wie lang das ist
warum sie diese viele blumen
hmm was ich denn jetzt mit haben jetzt
gerade nochmal eine menge bruch
steintreppen gemacht so dass wir uns
hier erstens nicht mehr den kopf stoßen
und so ein bisschen entspannter hoch und
runter lauf guck mal die sonne geht auf
die sachen hier werde ich jetzt einfach
mal mitnehmen und den rest hier lassen
und der höhle jetzt auch einfach mal
tschüss sagen das ist auf jeden fall
deutlich entspannter hier gerade mit dem
bruch steintreppen würde aber trotzdem
sagen noch mal ne kurze time lässt wie
ich jetzt versuche mein zuhause zu
finden
[Musik]
so dass immer wieder zu hause angekommen
so schwer war es tatsächlich gar nicht
hier wieder nach hause zu finden es ist
auf jeden fall richtig gut dass ich die
ganzen schienen habe es ist zwar nur 1
beck aber das wird uns auf jeden fall
deutlich weiterhelfen jetzt kann ich
euch hier auch immer zeigen sich das mit
mit den aktivierungs schienen hier
vorgestellt habe kann ich jetzt nämlich
einfach hier neben packen hier vorn habe
ich zwar noch keine redstone fackeln
dann nicht mehr auch nicht gerade nicht
machen weil ich gern holz dabei habe
aber so vom ding her soll das ganze dann
funktionieren wir können auch mal schon
mal eine kurze testfahrt machen deswegen
hab ich nämlich exakt die lore
mitgenommen denn man kann das ding jetzt
hinsetzen schiebt das ein bisschen an
setz mich rein und raus geklickt nicht
dumm
ich setze die lore hin schiebe sie
ansetzt mich rein und wenig dumm baum
werde ich herausgekickt ist aber auch
egal freunde ich würde sagen bevor wir
die folge jetzt heute werden schauen wir
uns doch mal eben ganz kurz die
schildkröten vorne an weil hier ist
überhaupt nix geschlüpft geht nichts
voran alters ohne kaka na ja ich gehe
auf jeden fall jetzt mal ein reines zu
mir ins haus sicher meine ganzen sachen
und meine lieben freunde wenn euch diese
xxx xxx höhlen folge gefallen hat dann
lasst gerne gerne gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video ihr da schreibt mir
wo ich jetzt hier gerade auch in der
kiste gesehen habe auch gern mal unten
in die kommentare was ich mit diesem
dreizack machen soll
bei der ist er komplett tot ich weiß
nämlich den in wiederherstellen soll
klappt das hier drin nicht irgendwie so
machten die hier geht gar nichts oder ob
ich zwei drei tage brauche schreibt zwar
gerne in die kommentare ich
kann ich mehr ich habe fast drei stunden
gerade aufgenommen abonniert main kanal
wenn ihr die nächste folge minecraft mit
luca übermorgen um 20 uhr nicht
verpassen wollt wir sehen uns ja
[Musik]